anne sylvestre cela fait longtemps que
vous flânez dans le monde de la chanson
je ne sais pas si le verbe flâner je
n'ai pas fait que flâne et le vrai mot
donc on verra tout à l'heure vous avez
pris c'est vrai en revanche des chemins
buissonniers je me demande si vous ne
souhaitez pas aujourd'hui aller sur la
grand-route haut mais je pense que j'y
suis depuis quand même quelques années
maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est être sur la grande
les chemins buissonniers en général sont
les chemins qu'ont choisi or mes chemins
de traverse je ne les ai pas choisis
je pense qu'on les a plutôt à plat l'art
et la grand route et on m'a fait prendre
des petits chemins sylvestre votre vie
est faite d'étape parfois difficile il
ya eu des rendez vous manqués os x même
dit que dire qu'il ya eu des traversées
du désert mais vous m'avez dit anas
tinqueux aujourd'hui vous étiez là où
vous souhaitiez être oui mais c'est
d'ailleurs extraordinaire de
d'être arrivé saine et sauve finalement
et sans avoir perdu la joue l
enthousiasme
bon ça je le dois je crois beaucoup à la
rencontre avec les gens pour lesquels je
chante avec vous-même aussi avec une
exigence
oui bien sûr mais c'est ça en fait on
pense je pense je crois au départ qu'une
exigence est limitative alors qu'elle si
on la tient
c'est pas toujours drôle en et nous on
est quelques fois un petit peu seul en
face de soi des autres mais si on se
tient à des exigences
on arrive au bout on n'a pas la parole
était besoin de plus regardées lé
période noire vous en vous ont aidé à
vire vous entendrez chez vous en effet
oui en effet pas exagérer on dit ça
après un oui oui c'est bien de pouvoir
encore le dire après mais je vous ai
voulu quand même s'ils ont enfin voulu
quand tout s'est arrêté avec ce qu'on a
appelé la vague yéyé
quand tout s'est arrêté pour moi et pour
beaucoup d'autres personne ne l'avait
voulu chez nous personne m'ont ensuite
quand j'ai vous savez quand vous voyez
tout d'un coup que vous disque
on voulait fait beau et que à chaque
fois on a l'espoir qu'ils vont marcher à
chaque fois cet espoir est déçu on se
désespère maintenant si on ne veut plus
quand j'envoie mes disques que les
écouter ou les faire écouter je m'en
fiche complètement
mais il a fallu quand même 21 ans pour
que j'arrive à ça va pas tout à fait
bien dommage
bon bah je trouve que c'est bon j'ai une
extraordinaire santé c'est tout mais il
y en a qui n'ont pas cette santé est qui
et qui aurait dû kika bonnes ondes
oui c'est moi je trouve ça très très
tristes vous n'avez que très peu de
relations avec le monde qui change tout
à l'heure vous disiez ces scènes où l'on
mêle le commerce et le reste mais
beaucoup de chanteurs quand même parce
sur ses seules d'en louer les accusés de
malhonnêteté l'envoi du tout je pense
que je ne sais pas ce qu'ils leur ski
leur prends je ne sais pas pourquoi un
jour ils sont attirés par ça je pense
que on est toujours leur et vous savez
on est toujours on se laisse toujours
leur est de même quand on signe un
premier contrat qui vous met au bagne
parce qu on est très content de faire un
disque on s'imagine que de faire un
disque c'est merveilleux et ensuite on
le regrette toute sa vie maintenant je
pense qu'il ya des leurs comme ça vous
allez avoir une consécration
moi je préfère mais je sais que je ne je
ne je sais que moi je peux faire ça mais
je ne comprends très bien ce qui marche
avec alors ceux qui vous écoutent dans
ce moment et qui seraient tentés de
faire une carrière parce que ils sont
nombreux ceux qui écrivent des textes
ceux qui écrivent des musiques bien ceux
qui pensent que il suffit de se
présenter quelque part pour que cela
marche vous leur conseiller de continuer
d'y croire mais je pourrais pas leur
conseiller de faire comme j'ai fait
parce que c'est quand même trop dur je
sais pas si
si beaucoup enfin c'est pas
extraordinaire
disons que ma vitalité m'a fait surnager
c'est tout enfin vingt ans comme vous
lisiez de travaux divers d'attentes
c'est quand même le temps de réfléchir
aux 6-12 ans de l'entrée en soi oui bien
sûr bien sûr mais en fait
bon si on me demande de quoi je parle
dans mes chansons je dirais je parle de
moi mais ça veut dire que je parle de
tout le monde parce qu'en fait quand on
sait quand on commence à se connaître un
petit peu ce soit on est capable
d'expliquer aux autres certaines choses
vous même pas d'expliquer mais de
trouver les mots c'est tout vous estimez
donc anne sylvestre que le monde de la
chanson est en fait une mafia non pas
tout entier il ya je pense quand même
maintenant en gros deux courants il ya
deux camps quels sont ces décès de camps
roms c'est pas difficile il y à il y a
ceux dont on parle beaucoup qu'il ne
mérite pas à je ne sais pas il n'est pas
question de mérite je ne parle que de da
proche du public il ya ceux dont on
parle beaucoup auquel on donne beaucoup
la chance d'être connus ou reconnus par
par un public et qui ne sont pas
forcément ceux qui vendent le plus de
disques ou ceux qui remplissent le plus
leur salle et pays un tas de gens dont
on n'entend jamais parler qui ont un
très gros public et qui déplace du monde
et qui remplissent des salles pas les
mêmes il faudrait peut-être expliquer
quand même très vite les choses parce
que on peut poser après interrogation
certain que vous refusez parce que
justement ils vendent du disque parce
qu'on les a un peu parce qu'ils passent
souvent à moi je suis regardé les
émissions de télévision semestre
il ya certaines émissions ou passent
d'ailleurs parfois toujours les mêmes
mais ce sont les plus grande audience
si l'on s'en tient aux seuls sondages
qui peut être d'ailleurs très contesté
il faut dire ces gens là font une écoute
mais samuel doe qui prennent tout le
monde
oui mais cela reste qu'ils ont donc le
public vient vers eux une écoute
télévision oui oui mais est ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on va voir quel public
viennent les voir dans les salles on ne
dit pas on dit quand quelqu'un passe
quelque part on ne dit pas quand
quelqu'un remplit
quelque part on dit pas non plus quand
les gens des commandes leur tournée moi
quand je faisais des cars de sale j'ai
toujours dit je fais des cars de salles
mais de bon car deux salles parce qu'ils
ont toujours été merveilleux j'ai fait
des tournées déficitaire mais je faisais
des tournées quand même parce que
j'avais l'impression que c'était semer
et maintenant je récolte anne sylvestre
vous avez changé depuis 20 ans où vos
buts sont différents non je changeais
bien sûr ce serait dommage de prendre
des années nan mais j'parle la mission
que vous étiez un pas mais je n'ai
jamais une mission en fait j'ai une
mission à posteriori non je n'ai pas une
mission n'avait envie de faire des
chansons c'est tout et j'avais envie de
faire des chansons qui étaient les
miennes et qui me ressemble c'est à dire
je me suis jamais posé de questions j'ai
marché
d'instinct c'est bien après je me suis
aperçu d'abord que déjà ce que je
faisais en débarquant avec mes premières
chansons pouvaient sembler un peu
subversif un peu déplacée parce que je
n'étais pas conformes mais ça je ne le
savent pas je ne me suis pas posé de
questions
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de base est
conforme mais ne pas être conforme à
l'image de la chanteuse tel quel et
quand elle arrive une chanteuse
physiquement ou moralement doit montrer
ses fesses et doit
correspondent à une image je ne
correspondais pas cette image ni dans
mon langage niland ma façon d'être bon
gars ça je ne le sais en fait je ne le
savais pas je les suis après comme j'ai
su aussi longtemps après qu'un certain
moment j'avais bien marcher m'aurait
fait plaisir de le savoir mais dans une
autre provision vous auriez eu la même
vie un peu de solitude quand même lors
de la solitude
quelle solitude celle qui n'est pas
conforme
je ne sais pas je n'ai pas comment dire
je crois que là la chose la plus
particulière que j'ai c'est que je
jamais une sur scène la même personne
que je suis à côté c'est à dire que je
me fabrique absolument pas une image il
ya un personnage pour aller sur scène tu
fais que les gens s'y retrouvent
est ce qui fait aussi que j'ai une j'ai
une approche très facile du public ou
des gens que je rencontre dans la rue
dans le métro sur sa natte ça ne
changent pas j'ai là je suis là même
admettant que vous ayez sacrifier à des
complaisances à des concessions où vous
seriez arriver plus vite arrivé dans le
sens où on arrive à faire des choses qui
plaisent au jour et du fric peut-être
non je ne crois pas j'aurais d'abord je
ne pense pas que j'aurais été capable si
je n'ai pas la nature à ce genre de
chose les concessions de fond du mal
alors je les évite
non je serais pas arrivé vous êtes
devenu un art is au complet qu'il n'y
ait pas de féminin artisans non c'est
dommage qu'on peut la montée je suis
passé artisanes oui on peut je suis pas
que ça je suis je suis commerçante aussi
c'est à dire qu'il faut fabriquer magic
triste mais il faut vendre à la 10 et
vous savez être commerçante
oui mon produit est bon
alors j'ai pu le garantis non c'est pas
de la vanille que je suis pas du tout
vaniteux suis même très modeste mais
stable non je sais que mon produit est
bon je me donne assez de mal quand même
pour qu'il le soit et puis je vous
disais tout à l'heure que vous me
parliez de mission d'ailleurs j'ai pas
fini parce que il n'y avait pas de
mission mais je me suis aperçu au bout
de deux beaucoup d'années que en fait
j'avais gagné une espèce de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des gens qui en
fait trouver dans mes chansons des
choses qu'ils avaient cherché à exprimer
je me suis aperçu que au bonheur ça
servait à faire quelque chose c'est à
dire que les gens comptaient sur moi
comptez pas sur moi sur mes chansons
donc je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait que
je devais absolument ne pas les décevoir
et puis continue il y a deux vies chez
anne siegrist une seule non liées à la
vie qu'elle mène avec ses chansons qui
sont pour tous les publics
et puis l'autre vie qu'elle offre aux
enfants est souvent lorsqu'on parle
d'anne sylvestre on parle on pense aux
en face à angers non mais ça ne me gêne
pas mais j'ai failli devenir la
chanteuse pour enfants exclusivement
parce que il se trouve que mes petites
chansons un tel succès que je n'ai qui
m'a dépassé finalement et qui s'est fait
tout seul avec le puissant soutien de du
monde enseignant parce que ça je dois
vraiment ce sont mes agents de promotion
les plus sûres et sans vos commerçants
baissent en mai représentant en finale
non mais ça c'est à une diffusion y
avait pas mal d'accord oui à sa fiancée
sont nombreux oui non et s'il ya une
diffusion absolument extraordinaire donc
ça
c'est ça c'est devenu tellement
envahissant mais les gens font tellement
attention à tout ce qui touche leurs
enfants que on aurait pu tenter
d'oublier que je faisais autre chose
d'ailleurs j'ai des problèmes avec ça
donc il faut que j'explique à chaque
fois que je ne fais pas de tour de chant
pour les enfants et que le tour de chant
du de tournai sont pour les grandes
personnes enfin les grandes personnes
quand même à partir de 13 14 ans parce
que c'est à cet âge là que je les
récupère anne sylvestre vous dit
beaucoup de choses dans vos chansons et
il a les mêmes certaines qui sont des
cartes de visite alors on pas peut-être
demander à l'une d'elles de vous
présenter le titre comment je m'appelle
[Musique]
c'est vous le savez comment je m'appelle
vous me le dire
vous me le dites
si vous le savez comment je m'appelle on
je les oublier vous me le dire et je les
oublier
quand j'étais petit et que j'étais belle
on ment ruben heads neiges
on m'appelait fleurs sucre ou bien dans
telles j'étais le soleil
j'étais la pluie quand je fais plus
grande et la salle
jetez la couleur
le montage lee
on m'appelait gars comme apple
j'étais quelques notes comment je
m'appelle pour me le dire
le libre
si vous le savez comment je m'appelle
où
je les oublier
mais
je les ai
je pris 15 ans que s'ouvrit le monde je
cru qu'on allait enfin me
mais j'ai tellement j'étais là
ronde
j'étais là pour le vernis de l'homme
une et quand alors j'aimais quand je
fait sourire quand je suis en vole quand
je fus lilas j'ai appris que j'étais
vents contraires
dit que j'étais personne que j'étais pas
comment je
si vous le savez comment je m'appelle
pour me le dire et je les oublier
je les oublier
quand je fus berceau et puis biberonne
j'oubliais tout ça en vaut pürro
puis me réveiller un matin orson jeter
marmota ces pierres
vienne j'étais ravi dieu
j'étais route digne on appelait soupe on
n'appelait pas j'étais paillasson quand
docu
je te l'entendre mes propres
lensois com en jambes
pour me le dire
le délire
c'est vous le savez comment je mens
on me le dirait
gray je les oublie
un jour un jour du fond de ma tombe
j'entendis des voix qui se rappelait
plaisir et douleur souvenirs vonthron
j'étais vivante et on m'appelait peu
portal heures
les cages le temps qu'il faudra pour 100
m
je saurai quoi mettre autant d'argent
pour commencer mon nouveau quartier
comment comment jeu
je vais vous le dire et je vous le dirai
je sais maintenant comment jma
c'est pas demain que je l'oublierai
[Musique]
que je n'oublierai
que je le doublais
anne sylvestre vous savez maintenant
comment vous appelez les comme vous avez
toujours pas je crois que je m'appelle
femmes
allomo femmes ça doit être ça
des sonorités plus à fait particulière
donc on ne donne pas vous lui donnez moi
oui enfin je ne sais pas je trouve qu'on
attache beaucoup de riz peau enfin on se
définit beaucoup dans une chanson moi
j'étais là à toute vitesse quelques mots
j'étais là moche et la ronde comme si
vous regrettez une oui je regrette quand
même oui je sais que oui qu'est ce que
c'est mais je veux dire que je regrette
de n'avoir pas été fille maintenant par
exemple quand même je vois les les
enfants les jeunes entre 12 et 18 ans
accepte beaucoup mieux en détail jusque
dans l'habillement jusque dans la façon
d'être dans la façon de se comporter
je pense que on m'a beaucoup
blessé à l'époque vous a blessé vous
vous êtes blessé lui-même jeté vouliez
différentes
oui mais vous savez j'ai eu bon je pense
que c'est pas c'est pas une chose
inutile à dire parce que il a expliqué
j'étais pas comme on doit et ça dure
encore je dire qu'il ya une espèce de
terrorisme qui s'exerce à l'égard des
filles et des femmes des hommes aussi
mais moins qu'ils sont qui dépassent un
certain volume ou un certain un certain
poids il ya cette espèce d'image quand
vous imposez à laquelle on ne correspond
pas peut-être confort le oui mais je
suis très fâché pique des colères à
cause de ça j'ai aussi fait d'autres
chansons dont une mode drôle qui
s'appelle pas de prix on peut dire c'est
ce n'est pas juste bon par exemple en ce
moment vous vous promenez vous regardez
sur les murs vous voyez d'une part des
photos de dames ultra-minces ultra choix
attaques des belles et beaux vêtements
si vous essayez de les acheter vous ne
les trouvez pas d'autres pas envoyer des
publicités pour des crèmes pour des
chantilly les manches alors je dis qu'il
ya quelque chose qui ne va pas ou alors
il faut absolument qu'on interdise la
publicité pour les pâtisseries voyez il
ya une cassure quelque chose qui ne va
pas et je suis bon sans doute on va dire
que je que je parle de choses un petit
peu futiles un peu bête et c'est pas
vrai parce que font partie de la ville
mais oui et malgré bien qu'on le sache
on se laisse imposer une certaine image
et quand on n'est pas conforme à cette
image là on souffre mais il faut savoir
quand même que certaines des robes que
l'on présente dans les magazines ne sont
jamais mises par personne mais oui mais
il sait il s'agit avant lé magazine holà
je voudrais créer un magazine pour les
pour les tailles au dessus je sortirai
les traits de choses intéressantes à
faire mais parce que dans les magasins
aussi et on ne trouve jamais alors il
yal'autre ferme l'autre frage était
paillasson l'entravent à mes propres pas
oui j'étais payaso veut dire
vous savez c'est pas laisser aller en
fait je parle non je parle pas que de
moi là en fait c'est la recherche de
l'identité de tout
l'entrée oui paillasson c'est on se
réveille paillasson le jour où on
s'aperçoit que insensiblement on s'est
laissé piéger par certaines choses
remarquez moi je ne suis pas en fait je
suis pas ça parce que la poussière je la
vois pas le ménage ça m'a jamais inspiré
et jeu est en fait je n'y attache pas
une grosse importance vous faites le
ménage non donc vous avez quelqu'un pour
le faire
déjà je le fais un petit peu non je n'ai
pas quelqu'un pour faire le ménage
enfin à la maison celui qui est celui ou
celle qui a le plus gêné par quelque
chose le fait c'est ce que vous appelez
la liberté oui
non mais je ne suis pas non plus pour
que le désordre entre à la liberté d
autres enfin le jure c'est mais je ne
suis pas du tout du tout une maniaque
j'ai eu quelques fois pour s'occuper de
mes enfants je prenais des filles au
pair des étrangères qui étaient des gens
de la famille finalement et j'ai
toujours
j'aurai toujours dit au début qu'on le
ménage c'est une chose mais s'entendre
avec les enfants c'est quand même tout à
fait autre chemise en quel âge vous en
fera j'ai une fille qui va avoir 18 ans
et une deuxième qui veut qui a 12 ans
donc elles ont suivi votre votre montée
dans la chanson votre arrivée dans la
chanson elle vous ont accompagnés oui
ils savent ce qu'elles ont souffert avec
vous est ce qu'elle réussisse le dr
souffert il faut quand même pas exagérer
certaines vous avez connu la vraie
traversée du désert lorsqu'elle ne fait
rien on souffre oui mais j'ai eu et j'ai
vraiment beaucoup compensé à ce moment
là heureusement c'est à dire que je me
suis je me suis occupé totalement de mes
filles j'ai continué à écrire des
chansons
mais en fait heureusement qu'à cette
époque là j'avais mes filles je très
jeune et que ma foi j'ai compensé là
dedans mais mais ça n'aurait pas pu
durer
beaucoup plus longtemps parce que je
serais devenu urgent et elle aime ce que
vous faites beaucoup et elle se
lanceront dans la chanson allez retourne
on ne voulait pas moi je pense qu'elles
voudront ça m'est égal c'est parfois
vouloir conseiller pas un mais je leur
déconseille aurait pas non plus non non
alors sûrement pas si elle se met c'est
même pas une question le gérant ne me
demandera pas maman veux tu que je fasse
ça quel est votre première exigence
c'est la dignité
oui c'est la dignité dans tous les
domaines vous êtes responsable de joue
d'abord de vos enfants de ce que vous
chantez aussi certaines de ce que vous
dites oui absolument
et vous voulez convaincre jeu oui je
veux faire comprendre
vous êtes sûr d'avoir raison vous les
faire partager alors j'ai raison pour
pour certaines choses je crois avoir
compris certaines choses j'en comprends
aussi beaucoup d'autres
vous étiez autrefois d'une agressivité
certaine je suis toujours agressive
c'est quoi être agressés à nous dit
voilà bien l'agressivité et selon la
personne qui qui la montre dans une
qualité soit un défaut en général pour
une femme c'est un défaut pas pour un
homme
non c'est bien c'est l'ambition c'est un
caractère une femme quand elle a un
caractère il est où bon me veut pas du
caractère c'est vrai nom je suis là je
n'en remets pas ses vrais bons ont
toujours dit que j'étais agressive parce
que justement j'avais de la dignité et
je précise quand on m'agresse bien sûr
et si jamais agressive avec les gens qui
sont non ce n'est pas demain qu'il y
aura cette fameuse égalité que l'on
réclame entre les hommes et les femmes
elle est possible à votre avis oui on va
faire comment une égalité différentes
une égalité je veux dire dans la dans la
tolérance bien sûr c'est pas l'égalité
est un mot tellement imbéciles égalité
il faudrait une cohabitation juste
tout aurait été plus facile pour vous si
vous aviez des garçons
enfin sûrement je pense que ça aurait
pas été aussi bon quand même cc recélant
pour certains aussi pour certains hommes
vous en connaissez beaucoup qui ont mis
tout ce temps là mais beaucoup aux deux
mêmes ou peut-être moins longtemps que
vous m'aidez des zones comme brassens
comme brel ont mis du temps c'est dix
ans dix ans maximum c'est déjà moins 20
enfin 12 20 disons 15 et où ces jeux ne
remplit les salles que depuis l'année
dernière
peut-être parce que vous n'étiez pas
sorti comment j'étais pas sorti il
n'avait peut-être pas dans les salles
bah alors si alors ça vient de quoi
pourquoi tout d'un coup avez vous
remplit les salles parce qu'il ya eu des
disques non je pense oui parce que je ne
sais pas pourquoi miraculeusement tous
émis un marché mieux quand je suis
devenu la productrice de mes disques bon
et d'une
peut-être que je vous ai d'ailleurs
cette chose cette fois là vous êtes
occupés oui mais il ya eu aussi une
chose c'est qu'il y ait un
rajeunissement du public vers la base et
puis une prise du camp de conscience je
pense de gens qui ont décidé d'aller
écouter sur les lieux des gens qui
n'avaient pas l'occasion d'entendre
ailleurs vous êtes demandé parfois qui
vous ressembliez parce qu'on veut
toujours collé des étiquettes pour en
faire des parallèles
j'espère que je ne ressemble à personne
oui mais vous êtes quand même d'une
école jeune ivan une chapelle à illies à
brassens avec ses personnages avec
l'auvergnat avec jeanne il a fait est
que ce clair avec son canada il y à guy
béart avec son éternité
il y à brel bah oui j'aimerais en fait
bon ressembler non mais disons que j'ai
toujours eu envie de
de me situer à mi-chemin entre brassens
et brel tout en étant différente et tout
en étant du côté de la femme c'est à
dire absolument le contraire vous
parlait parfois avec eux vous avez parlé
moi et brel hélas on ne pourra plus
parler mais il vous est arrivé de dante
engager la conversation sur ce sujet
avec les gens que j'aime beaucoup je
suis très timide et je le refais la
peine ce qui fait que je n'ai jamais
nous vous l'auriez souhaité bien sûr
mais je ne vous écoutait pas j'ai pas
essayé alors vous risquez aussi dans
votre univers où vous essayez la
rencontre c'est un effort des deux côtés
est ce que c'est bien la peine je veux
dire que je les rencontre dans leurs
chansons moi je trouve pas jamais su si
j'admire vraiment beaucoup quelqu'un je
ne saurai jamais même poser puis à paris
vous avez besoin d'admirer je me sens
aimé ya une chanson une autre chanson
qui peut bien définir également votre
univers elle a pour titre les gens qui
doutent je crois qu on peut s'y
reconnaître enfin beaucoup peuvent s'y
reconnaître enfin on verra après les
gens qui doutent
[Musique]
j'aime les gens qui tout les gens qui
trempent écoutent leurs coeurs se
balancer
j'aime les gens qui disent qui se
contredisent et sens dénoncé
j'aime les gens qui tremble que parfois
il semble capable de juger
jme les gens qui passent moitié dans
leurs godasses et métiers noté
j'aime leur petite chanson
me suis pas fait pour des cons
[Musique]
j'aime ceux qui paniquent ceux qui sont
pas logiques enfin pas comme il au
ce qui avec leurs chaînes pour pas que
ça nous gêne font un bruit de grelots
ceux qui n'auront pas rente de naître au
bout du compte que des ratés le
[Musique]
sudhir délivrez nous du pirée garder
bon jeu
leur petite chanson
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
quand
j'aime les gens qui n'osent s'approprier
les choses ans
ceux qui veulent bien être qu'une simple
fenêtre pour les yeux des enfants
[Musique]
ce qui sans oriflammes est daltonien de
la mignonne houleux
ceux qui sont assez pouvoir pour que
jamais l'histoire leur rende l'essonne
je me
petite agence ans
ma
parce que des cons
[Musique]
j'aime les gens qui tout mais voudrait
qu'on a foutu la plaie de temps en temps
et qu'on ne les malmène jamais quand ils
promènent leur automnaux
ton on leur dise que l'homme fait de
plus belle flamme que tous ces tristes
cuche
on remercie d'abord vécu
merci pour l'attendre
tant pis prophète
qui ont fait ce qu'elles ont pu
[Musique]
les mots sont durs sont vrais sont
exactes et aux fêtes sont bien choisis
sont tendres oui comme quoi on peut tout
dire sans vulgarité genre puis j'ai
prouvé que je savais écrire du beau
langage un petit peu alors les ratés du
coeur sont nombreux et puis les gens qui
doutent mais c'est ça avez vous douté
plus matin c'est toujours moins qu'avant
pas des mêmes choses
toi il faut douter quand même toujours
si on ne doute pas c'est terrible on
écrase tout lorsque vous faites une
chanson anne sylvestre vous d'abord vous
imposer un texte et ont travaillé
d'abord un texte d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
seulement une mélodique dont on pourrait
être sûr qu'elle sera connue qu'elle
deviendra à la mode
c'est la première chose c'est le tac des
choses à dire oui mais c'est en même
temps c'est à dire comme pendant que
j'écris le texte j'ai la musique qui se
fait dans la tête et ensuite je n'ai
plus qu'à la reconnaître et puis vous
êtes femmes d'abord porteuse d'eau ah
oui bah oui mais en fait bien sûr je
veux dire que c'est c'est évident c'est
pas rien c'est mon sujet et je ne
connais que ça féminines d'ailleurs
féministe oui juste enfin oui parce que
je sais qu'il est assez bien porté en ce
moment de de désavouer ce monde c'est un
petit peu pourquoi bien porté je sais
pas j'ai entendu pas mal de se défendre
en fait alors qu'elle faisait oeuvre
exemplaire finalement et sans doute donc
féminine donc féministe venir mais se
défendre d'être féministe vont avec les
10 mai dire non non non j'ai évidemment
j'ai des idées comme ça mais je ne suis
pas comme celles qui
moi je regrette je suis comme toute
seule qui parce que en fait quand on est
sur un bateau on va pas dire désavoué le
moteur parce que parce qu'il fait de la
fumée je pense que de toute façon tous
afn individualités ça veut dire quoi
être féministe le mot lui-même il oui
cet idiot c'est un mot qui a été avec un
grain c'est un mot qui a été forgé par
ce que il faut des mots en iste pour
constater que quelque chose existe avant
il y avait suffragettes oui oui c'est
aussi un mot aja nuance péjorative
non je veux dire que on est obligé de
forger un mot on l'a forgé parce que
effectivement on ne pouvait pas dire
femme parce que ça c'est galvaudé je ne
pouvais pas dire féminine pas ce que ça
veut dire tout à fait autre chose
on pourrait dire femme qui a conscience
de sa dignité
par exemple c'est beaucoup trop long je
veux dire que c'est une
c'est une question de dignité mais je ne
suis pas d'accord du tout pour
pour faire semblant de ne pas en être de
toutes celles dont on parle et qui sont
comme ci est comme ça même de celle du
vent très loin mais mais il faut
toujours dans chaque évolution dans
chaque révolution il ya toujours une
pointe avancée sans laquelle rien ne se
ferait rien se saurait c'est tout et je
trouve absolument indigne de désavouer
moi je suis quelqu'un qui se bat seul
solitaire bon mais mais je me bats je me
suis toujours battu pour ma dignité et
donc celle de mes petites soeurs
vous êtes d'accord sur le slogan homme
je voulais que c'est ridicule c'est
ridicule
non ces hommes vous avez été mal élevés
nous aussi et il serait peut-être temps
qu'on en parle c'est différent déjà mais
c'est sonic de la maladresse et vous
êtes prête pour tous les combats on peut
tout dire dans une chanson enfin je veux
dire on est bien reçu lorsqu'on écrit je
sais bien qu'on peut vous dire je pense
que dans une chanson on peut dire mais
pas dispo en demi-teinte beaucoup plus
de choses que que effectivement dans un
discours c'est à dire que il faut pas se
moment là que la chanson soit absolument
parfaite
par rapport à son but et par rapport à à
son sujet je vous ai lorsque vous avez
retenu de votre enfance vous êtes je
crois et bourguignonnes et alsaciens
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de tendresse
une enfance heureuse heureuse au milieu
de milliers du malheur mais heureuse
j'ai retenu la mer votre père vous a
aidé qui vous hante et des imans ils
m'ont encouragé beaucoup la chanson
ruitz et les premiers qui m'ont poussée
qui m'ont dit qu'il fallait il
souhaitait que
fassier autre chose non pas du tout il
souhaitait que je fasse ce que j'avais
envie de faire mes parents m'ont
toujours considéré comme une personne
que mon père est grande confiance est
grande admiration pour moi vous
considérez voshix comme des personnes
certainement jeu j'ai passé mon temps à
l'heure alors expliqué qu'elle était
quelqu'un est dans quelque chose qu'il
fallait qu'elle s'en souvienne je pense
que c'est ça pourquoi avez vous changé
de nom pourquoi vous surtout choisi
sylvestre chasse
j'ai changé de nom parce que j'avais un
an impossible
et puis que j'avais envie d'en prendre
un mois et maintenant j'ai choisi
sylvestre par le plus grand des hasards
et sans songer du tout aux implications
de de ce mot c'est à dire je suis
président reste parce que c'était un
prénom que j'aimais beaucoup
et après coup je me suis aperçu quand on
l'a dit et puis c'était il y avait les
arbres même air dur etc
mais j ai pas pensé sur le moment alors
faudrait-il choisir son nom cela
voudrait dire que l'on recommence à zéro
oui c'est bien possible ça on choisit
son nom qui est le sien faire ne pas
irriter pourrait hériter si on a envie
mais j'aurais volontiers aussi pris par
exemple le nom de ma mère ou de ma grand
mère
on fait ça avec les prénoms déjà chez
dans certaines familles on donne on veut
un petit peu tracé enfin non mais donner
des possibilités à un enfant en lui
donnant des prénoms mais le nom c'est
tellement une chose oui on doit se le
faire tout à l'heure vous disiez que les
choses sont plus faciles aujourd'hui
enfin les gens sont mieux acceptés la
route est moins ferme et donc anne
sylvestre vous vous seriez arrivé trop
tôt
rée soesbee havre non je ne le dis pas
je ne dis pas que la route est plus
facile je dis que pour moi tout d'un
coup la route est devenu plus facile
parce que il se trouvait à mon public au
public que j'avais par exemple il ya
cinq ans lorsque je suis revenu tout
d'un coup chanter au thème des capucines
à ce public là qui était mon public
enfin qui avaient mon âge ou presque ou
un peu plus se sont ajoutés tout d'un
coup depuis deux ans une quantité de
lycéens de très très jeune qui se
retrouve absolument dans dance dans les
chansons que j'ai fait à mes débuts dans
les temps et dans celle que je fais
maintenant
bon je pense il s'est produit deux il ya
eu de temps c'est à dire que d'abord les
filles jeunes ont trouvé une image à
laquelle sur laquelle se projeter un
petit peu qu'elles ne devaient pas
trouvé je pense dans dans leur
environnement et dans ce qu'on leur
proposait et puis en un deuxième temps
maintenant il y a à peu près autant de
garçons qui viennent avec
peut-être parce qu'ils ont envie de
comprendre parce qu'ils ont envie de
commencer à comprendre
vous ne voudriez pas rester dans votre
tour d'ivoire d'ailleurs il y alors j'ai
pas tour d'ivoire j'ai pas de rideau à
mes fenêtres
je prends le métro et je vois les gens
le plus possible et quand j'ai fini un
tour de chant je vais je fais semblant
d'aller fasciné les autographes
en fait c'est simplement pour les
regarder sous le nez pour être pour être
au contact pour être au contact mais ce
que je trouve absolument miraculeux
c'est tous et on va tous ces enfants qui
ont l'âge de mes filles et qui par
exemple écoute de préférence on a
réparti la femme du vent ou lazare et
cécile qui est je crois une douleur une
de leurs chansons privilégié et al azhar
et cécile on pourrait peut-être écouter
on avait la nasa et cécile ça raconte
quoi c'est l'amour on écoute
tandis que lazard ssl se sentent en vue
cette nuit et que la lune de c
jusqu'au matin à paris
on dit qu'à foulard de bruits pour elle
à blanc puis thalassa
costumes
10 et de nabeul et d'argent
vous le savez tous village que cécile
est ce un rêve assez dans les herbages
et danser avec le vent on riait de cela
sans amis sans fiancée vire au départ et
de la marge et ne l'est jamais dansé
[Musique]
il
soit une amie
et pourtant aussi
de se cacher par un essai ils ont joint
leur solidité
ils ont partagé
van prenant la 2 2
2 c mais secrètement
au bout de quelques semaines
il parut taux à 10 ans
que dans sa jupe de l'est
cl
alors il fallut les entendre tous
criaient au déshonneur
mais c'est si le pied tendre a préféré
le bonheur
on dit que lazard et cécile se sont
enfuis ses amis
des imbéciles
grosse fait
pourtant jusque
ce sont tenus
je
ils ont tué
on aurait voulu peut-être dû voir cécile
dans les temps et sur la branche d'un
être trouvé la sarp en dedans sans gêne
on aurait pu suivre
gens sentiront
mais ce que l'amour des livres préfère
c'est mais vivant
mary's
[Musique]
fier
m
ni monde y compris
[Musique]
vous savez
formant deux anneaux bizarre
il se glisse autour d'eux
or ce qu'ils ont couru ensemble le
leur pit amende ou moi qui ne dormait
pas
zabo
aussi beau soit cécile toile hasard
apprenez à votre enfant
[Musique]
ces 10 m seulement
que jamais c'est pas
qui sème simplement
on ne sépare pas ceux qui sèment simples
gens vous ne l'avez pas lâchés en route
cette chanson jamais jamais je crois
qu'elle a 16 ans et je les mises en tous
mes tours de chant quelles sont celles
que vous avez abandonné
or ben je peux pas les citer toutes il y
en a je peux pas parce qu'il n'a trop
maintenant il ya celle que celle que je
garde toujours celle que dans chaque
tour de chant je ramène quelques
anciennes chansons la une que je n'ai
jamais lâché non plus et mon mari est
parti parce que elle a gardé ça fait
comment vous marier à partie par des
partis au matin d'automne parti je ne
sais où c'était une chanson
autoritariste on s'en est aperçu dix ans
après vous le saviez vous que moi je le
savais figerait bien sûr mais j'aime pas
dire les justement j'aime pas titre et
je ramène de temps en temps madame
avoisine la femme du ve en ligne que
j'ai chanté jusqu'à il y a quelques
jours 7 et tiens toi droit
et puis tout d'un coup à mon premier
concert de la rentrée
j'ai eu un énorme trou de mémoire je
n'ai rien retrouvé du tout alors je dis
bon c'est fini la lèze quel est votre
tube mais j'ai pas active c'est à dire
que sinon je n'ai pas de tube vous allez
alors je vais vous dire quel est mon
tube ça sa particularité est que
ne pas ils ne passent jamais à la radio
donc c'est un tube sur scène c'est une
chanson qui s'appelle une sorcière comme
les autres qui dure huit minutes
là c'est un peu du lumineux qui passe à
la radio chanté par pauline julien vous
avez des jantes et par les autres
beaucoup je suis très peu chantée par
les autres je suis actuellement chanté
par pauline julien parme arenberg et par
beaucoup d'interprètes anonyme dont
simone bartel
quand même mais c'est tout vous
souhaiteriez être chantée par les eaux
oui mais ça me plaît beaucoup plus
d'être chantée par des tas de gens dans
des tas de petites villes et de deux
maisons de jeunes ou de d'endroits
inconnus
je ne sais pas moi ce qui me plaît
énormément avec pauline julien sait
qu'elle chante les mêmes chansons que
moi celle que je me suis choisie pour
moi et elle les chante pour elle ça
c'est merveilleux parce qu' elle n'a pas
peur et la finale est à la chance que
vous avez vu anne sylvestre c'est la
voix une voix très particulière
ah oui ça c'est le truc en fait je sais
pas oui et c'est aussi une très une très
grande chance auprès des enfants parce
que ça ma voix leur plaît et c'est comme
ça d'un trait d'union
oui parents enfants oui alors que en
fait cette voie je crois aussi me
correspond complètement si j'ai pas fait
changer pas étudié et la voix s'est
formé
avec les années c'est à dire qu'elle a
gagné en amplitude et en force
vous chantiez dans les églises lorsque
j'étais jeune j'ai fait des gregorian
des merveilles j'ai adoré ça oui j'ai
joué dans les chorales ça aide
oui mais j'ai chanté dans des chorales
j'ai fait des tas de choses mais en fait
puis ensuite j'ai chanté pendant cinq
ans sans micros dans les cabarets ski
quand même vous forger un petit peu le
larynx et maintenant je me suis aperçu
que j'avais et que ma boîte est devenu
très fort je chante très fort il ya une
magie de la chanson oui oui c'est une
chose absolument privilégier c'est un
véhicule dangereux que finalement parce
que on peut faire passer je pense qu'on
pourrait inciter public toutes sortes de
choses avec une chanson mais c'est aussi
je crois qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
bien
avec des chansons à tout à l'heure et
sylvestre vous avez composé conjuguer le
mot féministe
vous avez souhaité dire ce que
représentait pour vous mais je crois
quand même que l'appel prioritaire c'est
l'enfant comme on l'appelle priorité je
crois que c'est la première
préoccupation
ah ben oui mais ça c'est une chose c'est
pas il ne s'est pas la première
préoccupation c'est une
je ne sais pas j'arrive pas savoir je
voudrais savoir jours des mails et si
c'est une chose acquise si c'était une
chose
il est il doit y avoir des deux vous
auriez pu abandonner la chanson pour vos
enfants je n'aurais pas fait de gaieté
de coeur mais heureusement j'ai eu des
enfants
en très bonne santé qui se sont élevées
très très bien qu'ils ont été vraiment
chouette jeu je n'aurais pas voulu
j'aurais pas aimé abandonné pour elle
parce que je les aurai rendue
malheureuse aurait été trop frustré en
fait à certains moments vous êtes
considéré que même comme un porte parole
louis une borne de parole je pense aux
chansons sur l'avortement je pense même
une chanson où vous défendiez gabriel
russie oui à qui on allait jusqu'à
interdire des mets mes jeux l'adef un
garçon plus je ne la défend des pas
c'était après je veux dire c'était un
petit peu les chansons pour essayer de
consoler après bon ma chanson peut
consoler maintenant on peut essayer
d'éviter que ça se reproduise moi j'ai
c'était une bonne phase oubliez surtout
oui c'est ça j'ai été indigné par cette
histoire
maintenant ma chanson comme vous dites
sur l'avortement qui s'appelle plutôt
non tu n'as pas de nom elle a six ans
c'est pas une chanson de circonstance je
veux dire qu'elle est venue après on en
a beaucoup parlé
encore une fois elle est passée à la
radio chanté par pauline julien qui la
chante aussi qu'il ya évidemment bondi
sur les gens sont les plus difficiles
porte parole vous savez alors ça me
rappelle une chose absolument énorme qui
est arrivé il ya très longtemps c'était
après donc ça te fameux vague yéyé on a
dit à moi je mets des guillemets partout
on en doute et je me souviens qu'un jour
il y avait un grand gala à la mutualité
ça effrayant
il y avait eu comme sa série de
chanteurs j'étais passé là dedans avait
fort bien marché savent était plein et
on avait titré anne sylvestre la jeanne
d'arc de lentilles et c'est pas beau ça
faut le faire oui c'est beau hein vous
avez toujours le sens de la fête
à tout à l'heure vous me disiez que vous
chantiez dans les églises bonjour au
gong non je chantais l'on met dans les
églises je chantais parce que j'adorais
le grégorien
non mais elle l'a fait c'est autre chose
la fête c'est à oui ça moi je suis maman
était alsacienne et ça je crois que ça a
beaucoup d'importance parce que dans les
familles alsaciennes on est on est très
fait on fait des cadeaux on s'est
énormément de cadeaux alors ça moi
j'adore faire des cadeaux j'adore
recevoir j'ai donc créé des occasions
c'est pas de fait on en fait j'adore
préparer aussi aimé mes filles sont
comme ça et elles sont comme vous l'avez
parce qu'il ya le cadeau du retour le
cas des parts qu'elle donne maladie le
cadeau que dentiste yalgado pour la
bonne note yalgado pour consoler d'avoir
une mauvaise note
oui au fait qu à tous via le cadeau de
la colère oui oman ont quand même donc
faussée par mais il ya des tas de choses
comme ça et puis crée des fêtes et puis
les petits gâteaux au chocolat les
sapins ça c'est merveilleux c'est
bientôt noël noël c'est la fête
messieurs oui c'est quand même pas par
hasard que j'ai pris un petit sapin
comme emblème de ma maison de production
vous êtes vulnérables aujourd'hui encore
bien sûr à l'injustice oui je suis
vulnérables à la justice je suis je
redoute par dessus tout la déception
mais critique beaucoup moins quand même
encore un peu quand même
oui bien sûr bien sûr je réagi
violemment quand j'estime une critique
injustifiée
vous écrivez vos textes vous écrivez
votre musique oui vous êtes tant qu
écrivain
oui fait plaisir de l'entendre parce que
c'est bien rare dans une rebelle parce
que je peux difficilement dire écrivain
public voilà écrivain public
non mais il m'est arrivé de dire par
exemple bon je prends des vacances parce
que je dois écrire me dit ah vous
écrivez un livre non des chansons vous
compter sur les autres ou vous ne
compter que sur vous je compte les
enjeux ne compte que sur moi finalement
pas pour la tendresse mais pour pour ce
que je fais
quant à peu près que sur moi il est
d'une autre chanson j'aimerais qu'on
écoute un peu peut-être pas complètement
parce que je crois que nous sommes
arrivés mais à bon port les pierres dans
le jardin juste le début page
[Musique]
et si je vous en plus c'est une bien
paysanne bien
ni serait opportune sur les arbres et
les petits oiseaux
[Musique]
les deux n'ont rêvé je chanterai mais
bien sa peau
il y aurait des lavandières et les
bergers et les troupeaux
et soyons pas radars ont dû être m un
jardin on y mettrait même un jardin
[Musique]
ça serait bien mais la duchesse de ses
sabots à l'aso p
[Musique]
partout elle posait ses peines
on voyait de
[Musique]
c'est une chanson très ironique joue oui
c'est un règlement de compte c'est qui
avec non c'est pas ça en fait ça remonte
à plus loin que ça quand j'ai commencé
on a dit que j'étais bucolique champêtre
etc salut à ses sabots la duchesse en
sabots bon ça m'a suivi
je ne savais est alors en plus on au
début effectivement on a dit il ya des
gens pour dire en c'est du folklore ça
nous empoisonnent bon aure ensuite le
folklore tout d'un coup c'est devenu
travail et le folk bon et c'est j'en
suis ravi parce que j'aime beaucoup mais
je veux dire que on a tellement embêter
avec ça au début on ne voyant que le
côté folklore et le côté campagne que
bon bah ça m'embêtait là j'ai voulu
régler mais quand est ce que vous aviez
fennell vous l'enterrez quoi comment ce
que vous aviez fenêtre vous l'enterrez
non non je n'enterre pas du tout parce
que je ne renie rien il ya une chose
aussi que qu'on n'a pas dit enfin et je
vois que dans le choix des chansons on
est encore tombé dans le même panneau ce
que je je fais à peu près autant de
chansons drôles que d'autres et que les
gens ne le savent pas enfin les gens
sauf ceux qui viennent m'écouter
anne sylvestre vous restez quand même
dans votre tour d'ivoire du nom je sais
c'est que je viens pour toi tu vois
avant tout à l'heure on a dit pas
d'olympia pas de pas de grandes scènes
et mais le chapiteau là bientôt vous
allez vous retrouver devant votre public
parisien où ça au château où ça aux
halles parce que c'est très particulier
ah bon non on vous suit pas particulier
c'est rigolo puis c'est un chapiteau
c'est bien puis
mon public qui aime bien ce genre de
salle et puis en plus on peut y faire
des prix de places normand une nouvelle
rentrée donc un nouveau district une
entrée non pas nouveau disque avant
alors ça c'est nouveau et des nouvelles
chansons
merci anne sylvestre
[Musique]